[Music]
[Music]
so beauty of the mixer board and just
ramped up the volume of life but I'm
here hello this episode is brought to
you by DirecTV now guys what a better
way to watch TV over the Internet then
DirecTV now guys you hop on your phone
you can connect it to Roku Apple TV you
can watch it straight on your TV or you
can watch on your phone around the house
mm-hmm the starting package of $35 gets
you 60 live TV channels on your phone
and if you go up to the top package you
get up to 120 channels go to DirecTV now
kommst ir e CT v now comm check it out
is a really great deal and it's gonna
change your TV watching life also guys
quip when it comes to your health
brushing your teeth is one of the most
important things that you can do might
as well do it with quip InStyle easy to
use small form-factor guys quit is an
electric toothbrush that packs just the
right amount of vibrations into a
slimmer design at the fraction of the
cost of the bulkier traditional
electronic toothbrushes right now quick
clip starts at just $25 and if you go to
get quip comm slash Jenna Julianne right
now you'll get your first refill pack
for free or click the link in the
description because that's GE tqu yp.com
/ Jenna Julianne it's really cool
actually let me check it out
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
just thinking about how with DIRECTV now
you could watch however many episodes
are of Oak Island when I realized the
other day how many episodes that show
I've watched and have been bamboozled by
it infuriated you watch this show and
every single time they click be you and
you click on it the next time every
single time I do they're like what are
they gonna uncover it this is
to some crazy story it could mean human
remains are actually gonna be found this
episode and then it's just nothing every
time it's nothing it's so bad
you get debated everything so bad I know
what they like there's like a little
enough stuff happening where you're like
okay next time it's gonna be the one
where they they break him in the
Chappell vault and they get to see
what's in there oh they found a piece of
parchment oh man this is gonna be good
and then no nothing happens no Rick and
Marty lagina should start a YouTube
channel cuz they would be the best
clique painters are well and I saw that
one of them is on a new treasure hunting
show like looking for Confederate gold
or something in Lake Michigan I don't
even know but I was like Oh what do you
like a treasure hunter I thought you
were devoted to Oak Island am I supposed
to lose my loyalty to Oak Island now
he's voted to making money off of your
curiosity made of my curiosity I'm
feeling very had the real treasures are
eyes isn't it the treasure is just the
$35 per month you're gonna pay to
DIRECTV now and never ever find tragedy
from watching that I've discovered the
what's buried on Oak Island okay it's
the money that that they can make off of
our eyeballs just it's it's like a
futuristic money their pain it's not
Templar gold it's not ancient relics the
series finale they're just gonna be like
and to finally reveal what we've been
looking for an Oak Island it is all of
your money that you've been paying yes
thank you and goodbye peace that's the
finale yeah and like the history of the
island is like six people have died
looking for its treasure and according
to legend one more will have to die in
order to discover what the Oak Island
treasure is and the seventh death is all
about collective souls for having
invested all this time into Yoshio isn't
it I'm kidding I still love that show I
will say this most recent season like
they've done a better job with the
pacing of the episode it's like they'll
they'll go talk to an expert or like
discover little stuff on the beach so
it's not like they don't find anything
like I'm being harsh right
but like the earlier seasons it's like
all building up to this very mediocre
moment and you're just like dude come on
nothing that's happened it's an
interesting show like some of the stuff
that they that they uncover and yeah
yeah but but very large but it always
goes nowhere and then they set you have
the same way the next step is out where
it's like okay they found this one thing
they're going to an expert they're
getting it examined oh this means X X
means Y y means a just kidding nothing
means anything we'll see you next week
for another like it's not their fault
like if production had any choice they
would have found like the most amazing
stuff well and I'm also waiting for a
treasure hunting show to actually yield
something of like believable worth like
it was for a lot of handheld on you you
have put on a couple different shows
there was one where that guy remember he
fainted and he had like that like weird
kind of out-of-body experience and then
he woke up and he's like where did I go
you remember that no they're like
they're looking to dig across this river
remember and the guy just like falls
asleep on the ground this guy like falls
asleep is it one of those like was it on
discovery really riding around on these
marshlands yeah I don't remember where
but there they get off the boat and they
ask this like local who barely speaks
English and he's like can we dig here
and basically like no so he faints I
know the show you're talking about I
don't remember the name like passed out
and then he woke up I know you like
shivered around the ground but it all
look very very sighs it didn't look like
a proper right guys human reaction near
when you're shooting a television show
all it takes is to walk up to a local
and say hey can we dig here for your
gold well and not to mock anyone with
any sort of PTSD or anything but like he
claimed PTSD and he woke up and he's
like well I thought I was you know back
in whatever and it all was just like
whoa like this this came out of nowhere
didn't even it like him didn't even make
any sense who knows it could've been
real but it looked it looked really
stupid and so that's just my example for
these types of shows I'm waiting for one
of these shows to be like okay
we think that there could be gold down
in this swamp Marsh cave we're gonna dig
and then episode 2 there they go down
there and they find a mannequin made
purely of gold and they have to
investigate why but at least there's
something there right like I feel like
all of these are all just like lying and
hook and sinkers different I'm pretty
sure that that show you just referenced
was called The Legend of croc gold on
discovery and I so like however long ago
after it was right after this boy eaten
Jarrod I started realizing how many
shows there were of people looking for
treasure and the first I was spoiled
because the first one that I watched is
also on discovery it's called Cooper's
treasure I think and that one was legit
as [ __ ] and also billion dollar wreck
was also legit as [ __ ] those two shows
are in my opinion the exception to the
treasure hunting like obviously legit
they find and I've seen a third one that
about looking for Templar self or they
do find like a block of something um the
the the premise of them is legit so for
like Cooper's treasure it was this guy
was an astronaut and in the fort I'm
getting this all wrong but he was an
astronaut at some time in the lab in
this last century and he was actually
mapping shipwrecks from space and made a
like a basically a treasure map of
shipwrecks so you could only see from an
aerial view and he had the unique
position to heaven leg up yeah so he
would he they literally had like audio
you know tapes or whatever of him in a
[ __ ] spaceship flying over the world
where he'd be doing his astronaut job of
whatever it was he was doing and then he
would go silent over those Caribbean
areas where he was like actually mapping
out shipwrecks and then you know because
he was a [ __ ] astronaut an adult that
point and pretty busy he searched for
like a little bit before he died but
then he passed on the treasure map to
like his son and stuff and then his son
or whoever actually cool made it his
life's job so they do actually
investigate a couple of those shipwrecks
you know they find some stuff it's not
like they find a box of gold or anything
like that
but that one was legit and then
billion-dollar rec was about this ship
that had sank and they knew exactly how
much money was on it that when it sank
but the only problem is that it was like
feasibly too deep to dive down there so
it's just about them basically getting
all of the the stuff together to make
this really deep dive to contain like
the depths of the ocean or too deep to
go yeah because of the pressure it's
like a thousand or 1,200 feet down like
even with even with like the like like
submarines engine with modern technology
it was relatively hard for them they
were facing a lot of obstacles but that
that show was also surprising because
not only was the premise totally
plausible and not like [ __ ] but it
was the storyline of him and his wife
and this he has like a [ __ ] eyepatch
I was like this is a joke this isn't
real
but it the it was wild like I don't even
remember it but I just every time I go
on discovery this app and I'm just
looking for season two because I'm like
I need to know what the [ __ ] is going on
very invested in that storyline but them
as people was interesting hmm Cooper's
gold had like a couple of scenes where
it was like him giving his dad money
like there's clearly like some
production in there being like alright
we need a we need a storyline right now
all right pops get in there and ask your
son for some money it's like really
scripted sort of but the premise is very
real and the treasure is is real the
other ones that are like that show you
just reference the legend of crock gold
it's just like you can tell that they're
like cast and they go down there and you
know some of the the obstacles are
clearly real because they're like oh our
boat [ __ ] sink or something stupid
they focus on one - anything that
happens become so dramatic yeah they're
like panning for gold and that was also
the the lot of this is flawed that show
the one where the guy think it's the
legend of crock gold they do address the
fact that they're going into a foreign
country panning for gold and that
they're willing to give all of the gold
and profits to the government of that
country because all the rest of the
shows are like we're going we'll follow
this this mysterious trail of gold there
was that one yours it was do that one
word okay there was that one where it
made me feel like it was at least
legit because they were doing that and
all of a sudden they brought up the fact
that like a bunch of [ __ ] like
gangsters that was finding Escobar's
Millions that show was terrible it was
hyped up it was on history I think and
they they go into and they start getting
healed by these by these people right
they go into Colombia and they had they
had obviously Pablo Escobar had hidden
like I think a billion dollars there's
something insane just all over around
Colombia and the government had
recovered a lot of it and what this show
and they address that in that show too
that their labor transport work
yeah we're not legally cannot be like
okay guys I'm an American looking for
Pablo Escobar's millions I'm just gonna
come into Colombian dig it up myself and
take it on the plane with me walk it
through tears yes so they they do
disclose in the show like we're giving
it to the government we're just going
there because we're currently have good
they literally had a DJI drone they're
like we have cutting-edge technologies
GI drone that everyone knows what it
looks like except they had this like
fake overlay graphic of the of the film
it was shooting of the ground like it
was clearly put in there in
post-production of like mapping out
different subsections of different
magnetism x' and it was like dude that's
a that's a literally we came by that
exact and there's no modifications to it
but there was that one show where the
dude put a like some sort of tracking
device on the drone and instead of the
camera remember that yes - kind of like
map out where he was and [ __ ] and at
least you can see he modified this guy
it was just like out of the bottom well
yeah and it was like he was claiming
that it had some like infrared or
magnetic sort of malady right I'm like
oh yeah the military has it but you
can't buy it at Best Buy [ __ ] off so I'm
looking at that and that's not it with
that it's not but yeah so they're like
they're like talking to locals they're
trying to figure out where Pablo Escobar
hid cash so they can find it and they
start getting tailed and supposedly
tried to get run off the road by these
like rest areas people who probably work
for the cartel or whatever the [ __ ] well
yeah and what was frustrating about that
show is I did watch the whole thing I
believe to all of the episodes that have
available to me they literally found
nothing
like I'm not getting nothing like at
least in oak island they'll find like a
Templar cross or you know fragment of
interesting [ __ ] like a pile of gold but
like I'm into it alright that's why they
have had me hooked for 63 [ __ ]
episodes or whatever literally 63 hours
but like that show they found nothing
and I was like guys how is this a show
it's not how is that a show it ain't
watching you waste your time and create
some dramatic storyline in Colombia I'm
not into it not into it literally ain't
not into it
no but yeah some are better than others
but I do like it and I you know I Oak
Island is my first love and I am mad at
them but like I understand you know and
I'm here for it okay anyways that was
not I don't hate it I don't hate it I
don't hate it I just I think it's funny
that's all I would be very excited or if
you guys are into those treasure shows
Cooper's gold and billion dollar wreck
are actually good shows on Discovery
they're very interesting like if I could
watch billion dollar wreck over again
and not know what happens I would I
would give it yeah further further it's
a great a little overdramatic
no it's of age but this actually was not
what we attended for this party totally
not
first of all Julian has had some what
month old piping hot tea that you need
to spell it's tea time which added
Julian tea time would you let me keep it
it's annoying in long periods of time
Julian please set up this piping tea
okay we've been meaning to share this
old Julian has mom my teeth it is piping
hot but it's really not that's great
from my eyeballs but we keep forgetting
to share it on the podcast we want okay
so set it up plate I have celiac disease
I am gluten free so that naturally
attracts me anyone in the spotlight or
Hollywood or anyone of you know a public
figure who has a following who is also
gluten free I am attractive that person
in in a way of like I want to see what
they're up to right because they were
kind of representing us as Celia
for gluten-free people who actually have
to adhere to a diet or whatever one of
those people his name is Mark Cuban and
if you watch Shark Tank or any of this
stuff he does Mavericks the owner of the
Mavericks but he's an entrepreneur he's
a billionaire whatever he's very
outspoken about the fact that he is
gluten free I don't think he has celiac
but I think he is gluten free because of
his gluten allergy like a serious one
invests in I think multiple like
companies that that are gluten-free
foods or gluten friendly gluten-free
friendly and talks about it on Shark
Tank and like will literally only take
gluten free samples of food and people
will specifically specifically give him
only the stuff that he can eat like if
they're bringing something he can eat
he'll literally like not eat it which
we've always thought was like super cool
and rad and I love it I love that
because like as as you know that's what
I told you like I have you guys who
watch me so I try to be as outspoken as
I can because for the like handful of
celiac followers I have it means kind of
a lot yeah you guys have information and
whatever so that's how I feel about Mark
Cuban and I always looked up to the fact
that he was public about it and invested
in it both with his money and his time
and whatever I recently took a trip to
Minnesota for the Superbowl and we were
just wrapped filming our episode of our
last minute trip episode and we had gone
to the JLo concert that was kind of the
culmination of art that is the sound
that JLo makes and we heat that's that
that was the kind of combination of
filming so we pretty much turned off the
cameras right before it like right as
the concert was getting going and we had
this Super Bowl tomorrow so we were kind
of relaxed we were they actually put us
in this kind of you know for lack of a
better word like important people sweet
like there's a lot of like really
important people walk around there's
like Eli Manning Tim Tebow there's Remy
Malik Mark Cuban you rami malek yeah
calling said how do that's so rad I love
you me
yeah there's a lot of you know a lot of
people in Hollywood in sports or
whatever but Jerome Bettis was there I
mean even Peyton Manning was there a lot
of people anyway we were completely out
of place from the bachelor
Bibiana and Lauren were with us through
the whole [ __ ] thing though they like
I know they were at our Meetup they were
just chilling anyway so we didn't know
we were gonna be in this like box with
all these people we thought we were just
gonna be sitting and watching the
concert like everyone else they put us
in this box it's packed with people and
I see more Cuban and I actually before I
saw him someone was like Mark Cuban
scene I was like oh that's pretty cool
like I like him he's gluten-free [ __ ]
yeah so I decided to like take a lap
around the room to go get a drink but
also just like Nancy what's going on so
I leave my railing kind of spot this
concert really hasn't really gone going
yet so I leave my really spot I walk
around I see Mark Cuban and he looks
magical and real like a person and he's
I think he has some makeup on him you
know he looks like TV ready or whatever
and he walks I'm like walking around the
room I kind of stop and get my drink and
I'm sitting there and he walks over
across to where this the the food was
like the snacks and the food on the
table and I had already investigated and
known for a fact that I couldn't eat
anything because it was it was literally
like there was pasta and then there was
like seafood you know little hors
d'oeuvres and then there was like
sandwiches and I was like okay I'm not
gonna eat here or whatever right so he
walks over and someone points at the
food to him and he was like showing him
food and so he takes a piece of food and
he eats it and it looks like a sandwich
in fur for me I was like wait a minute
holy [ __ ] I'm stupid how did I miss that
like there's gluten-free food over there
even if it's not Ving and I didn't see
the gluten-free sign of what he's eating
because I know that he's eating gluten
free food right now right
he's Mark Cuban so I'm like for lack of
a better word looking at him from across
the room I watched him take a bite of
the sandwich and I see where he gets it
from like which tray he took it from so
as he leaves I let him like clear out
and I'm like waiting and waiting till
it's like appropriate and not stalker he
so I walk right where he was not to like
collect his napkin or whatever but I
walked to where he was because he took
his nappy and I would have taken it if
he didn't I'm joking
and I look at the sandwich attorney that
he just took a sandwich off of and sure
enough it is a straight-up regular bread
not gluten-free which is it mr. Cuban
is it gluten or is it gluten-free tell
me what's going on here what's going on
okay I want to be really delicate though
because I do know that I do not have
celiac disease you do well let me finish
I want to address that in the store part
of this is a good point but what I said
to Jenna and I called her that night
after the counts or whatever I was like
by the way I got something to tell you
told me that certain she loved it she
was like oh my god but I said one thing
I do know though is he is not ever
declared that he has celiac disease so
it's not like a person who has once
claimed that they are they have a
literal a genetic disease which doesn't
even disease it's like the way they know
it's like all celiac disease but it's
not not even like technically a disease
it's a genetic predisposition to an
autoimmune disorder really and if you
have celiac disease and you don't adhere
to a 100% gluten-free diet that's bad
and it's it's it's not good for your
bodies your lower intestines yeah your
body attacks itself the only cure for
that right now is if you die and luckily
it's a perfect cure right most people
with celiac adhere to a hundred eighteen
free diet and aside from the times when
you know restaurants are in Auto so
whatever they can be okay there's no
pain it's different than like something
like Crohn's disease which is like very
very more complicated so I said I know
he has no senior disease so I don't want
to just jump on him he might have a mild
gluten allergy that you might have like
you know brought into the spotlight at
times but maybe the allergy has kind of
died down since then who knows like it's
very possible that he just like outgrew
it or something right totally possible
but I do think it was really funny it's
also it's also a thing because UFC like
disease I do not but I've been exposed
because of you to a lot of different
attitudes about celiac disease gluten
intolerance gluten allergy like but that
let's agree because I think that you
know that these people exist too that
there are people that have different
levels of gluten intolerance all the way
up to Celia
disease that sometimes are hungry or out
or wherever and they really [ __ ] they
will eat gluten it is possible that Mark
Cuban was just so hungry that he needed
to eat something and just said [ __ ] it
in that moment which again as a Celia
but as a person with a dune allergy of
different levels varying reaction levels
I can't speak to that I don't know what
that's like right either way we're not
trying to shame him or anything I
thought it was so I love more Cubans
yeah the fact that he's been so visible
about gluten and it just as a whole as a
billionaire is like a cool guy you know
it's just so rad it's a win-win for
everybody but we just laughed so hard
though Julian was like oh sick there's
gluten-free sandwiches here yeah and you
know what you know honestly this this
could be if you're if you're a hardcore
into it and you want to call me out this
could technically be the pot calling the
kettle black because there was a time
you know in the this this last year in
2017 I did like a sort of a study on my
own I found this gluten free blog and it
was basically this guy who tested beers
for different level of gluten and I
decided to go off of the test that he
had had done on the beers and and give
it a shot like taste beers drink a beer
that isn't technically gluten-free but
under his million have lower than 20
parts per million or close to 20 parts
per million which is technically the
gluten free standard it just can't be
labeled as gluten free whatever and I I
did get in trouble with some people
online especially in the gluten-free
community because I was drinking beer
and I was doing it on online right for
people to see and I get that that's a
bad example but at the same time I was
pretty I was pretty open about the fact
that I was doing kind of like a where
you got but also I will say though to
you a couple of those beers that you
drink yourself that work technically low
enough parts per million to be gluten
free just couldn't be label gluten free
you didn't feel like super great after
you drink a couple of those beers yeah
one of them made me pretty sick guys
yeah one of them made me pretty sick
that's where your journey end and that's
one like three or four and then on one
of the last ones I was like I was
drinking the next day I got so [ __ ]
sick I was like okay this studies over
plate times up like it got real yeah but
I mean if you're Julian and you've been
or a celiac and you've been celiac
10 plus years now like sometimes it's
just exciting when you get that
information and no one's knocking you
and no one's knocking Mark Cuban if he
ate a [ __ ] sandwich it's made with
gluten like this is also a jokey it was
just funny we were just laughing and I
was like Julie you guys spill that pipe
you got a boy yeah but I'm also pretty
sure that we've seen him eat things with
gluten on Shark Tank and I'm just like
what's possible okay it's possible again
against our tank has spanned over what
10 years yeah he might have outgrown
that out the allergy it's possible and
it's it's a difficult subject to like
address after the fact oh yeah by the
way I'm not you know I mean either way
he's been really cool about being gluten
free and done a lot for that
yeah it's Turtles and it was cool that I
got to be in the room with Cuba right
shouts out to DIRECTV now for putting me
in that room oh and speaking of DIRECTV
now that's segue after you spilled tea
DirecTV now guys is the best way to
watch TV right from your phone right
from your Roku right from your Apple TV
devices anywhere in your house wherever
you are
you need to pop on and watch some live
TV you know watch them SVU you need to
watch them the challenge check it out
it's DirecTV now calm okay you can watch
on your phone with tablet you can cast
straight to your devices there's no
cable boxes or satellites or or any
long-term contracts it's all the
nonsense about traditional you know
cable and satellite models that just
like turns people off and it's clunky
this is new and this is sleek and you're
not locked in there's no long term
contract you can start with $35 and get
over 60 live TV channels right to your
phone or you go bump it up a little bit
and get 120 live to V channels like ESPN
Disney and TV History Channel all the
good stuff alright we personally have a
handful of shows that we watch I love
like I said the challenge SVU
general watch this island they're never
gonna find anything but if you want to
believe that they are you can watch it
on your phone with DIRECTV now it's
really great app check it out that's di
re CT V now there's 1t check it out
DirecTV now no more click the link in a
hard description
and when you're done watching TV go
brush your teeth and do it with quip cuz
clip is this new electric toothbrush
packs the perfect amount of vibrations
it's high-tech it's low-cost it's sleek
it's wonderful and they ship the refills
of the the refill packs like for the
brush itself because the brush head it
diminishes over time you can't just use
the same brush at overtime equip is nice
because it says hey we know that you
can't use the same brush it over time so
we're going to [ __ ] house we don't go to
this door we don't go to this store so
if you're a postman a fan or you like to
get you to deliver it and not leave your
house if you stay in your house just get
quick they send you the refill packs so
you're like a mailman thank you and then
you pop it on brush your teeth
good as new look how much shine you want
my teeth are right it's great and it
doesn't cost hundreds of dollars like
the other ones look at my teeth right
now it's amazing I can't see them your
moustaches you're learning them that's
right here got it this is what qyp does
amazing ok right now guys go to get
quick calm that's GE t qu IP calm slash
annejulien
you should think about getting a
subscription plan which refreshes your
brush a dentist recommended schedule
it's backed by science y'all delivering
a new brush head every three months for
just five dollars including free
shipping worldwide starts at just $25
for the initial product and you get your
first refill pack for free with our code
get quick calm / annejulien check it out
and then have a fresh breath the end all
right Julian what are we doing what are
we doing to finish this thing well so as
many of you know but probably not all of
you because it's not like YouTube shows
us any love you know what I'm saying
even though we mutually agreed this with
a good idea
I've done a Sirius XM show called the
YouTube 15 for years now I think it's
been since like 2014 or something I
think it's probably since 2014
it's been at least 3 years maybe four um
right now that was t.t i'll get you
follow us oh my god
stop yeah this is gonna take way too
long on my phone cuz they're all here
but I've done a Sirius XM show called
the you 215 and we basically play
whatever's the top 15 trendiest songs
from youtube that week on the radio
which is really cool like we've played
youtubers we've played Thanksgiving song
k-pop
yeah kpop like all this stuff that you
wouldn't traditionally hear on an
American pop radio station if it's
trending we play it and I think it's
just such a cool it was like when they
asked me if I wanted to do it I was like
I have no experience in radio I don't I
don't know how to do that you know who
cares just do it and I'm like okay like
feel free to fire me whenever you want
and I'll be waiting and they're just
like you still hired and I'm like sounds
good to me like I enjoy doing it it's
really fun and I just think it's such a
cool way to break down that barrier of
like independent artists don't have to
do all this crazy stuff to get played on
the radio that if you're trending you
Trent and a lot of the times you you
bring songs out and you beat them to
Radio absolutely and then they come on a
radio like a couple months later I
record that show every Thursday and
that's like right after my video day on
Wednesday do I hear oh yeah no they stay
up super late like cuz I'm just you know
to shoot at it upload all in one day is
a mess of a schedule and I never
recommend it to anyone and yet I keep
doing it yeah for real um but then
Thursday morning I wake up and I ride my
radio show every single week so what I
do is I get a list from Sirius XM of the
music they curate it I don't actually
handpick all of the songs obviously
because it needs to go by a certain
algorithm of trending and they do try to
keep it like you know instead of having
everything be new that week like there's
some songs that they want to keep trying
to like you know see what lands a little
bit so they send me the list and then I
rate the show so it's basically like
I'll go on people's Twitter accounts or
like try and figure out who all the
artists are for some of these people
there's no information on them because
they're just like us
Soundcloud artist that has like a few
songs on soundcloud and that's it but
you have to get a little creative
sometimes about like filling in this
this break of introducing this person
but as a radio host that's generally
what you're doing is like you're between
songs
okay the break is you're giving some
sort of commentary about the last longer
about what you think about the new song
coming up or about just a personal
anecdote about either so it's like yeah
Jenna that's the time she spends putting
into the show it's like writing that out
and it's not live so I have time to sit
and do all my research and find all that
stuff and then actually physically ready
to show out and then when we record it
I'm like reading off of what I've
written before it sound like I'm a live
DJ and I'm sitting here playing the song
and then talking about it and then
because a lot of people think that we're
in New York playing so a lot of times
when I'm writing my show I'm like tired
loopy but it helps cuz it makes it silly
and fun and light-hearted and stuff but
I'll be like around the house writing my
show like Juliet I'll be rubbish Oh like
Carmen can help me write my show like
help me write my show Carmen it's just a
joke so last week Julianne was also
pretty tired and loopy and I was playing
a song because it was on the show so I'm
watching the music video and like
reading the description and reading the
comments re and the feedback and he just
comes in and does this fake [ __ ]
impression of me like I'm recording it
like saying something about it and I was
like boy are you making fun of me like
what the [ __ ] was that if you used to
work in radio I'll tell you thank you
you so I was like okay Julian let's make
a fun game where you are now the host of
YouTube 15 on Sirius XM playing the
hottest music according to YouTube this
week i'm jenna Marbles ha ha listen to
the show okay so Julian I want you to
pick a year and a month and I will pull
up the actual show and you can do the
whole thing and and make it whatever you
want we don't have a soundboard for you
though
16 March 2016 let's look it up I'm
interested to see what was trending that
week March first okay would you like
March 1st March 30th March 9 but first
where's first ready for March first is
my time to shine baby oh no this is what
I wrote let me find you the actual show
oh how do I find this is in a folder
wait if I just search for it it's just
like spam for my email let me look at a
folder it doesn't matter I could take
anything I like fun is fun YouTube 15 is
the folder all right I just have to go
back here March what that's three right
all right then you wanted March first
hold on just give me one second I'm
almost there you have time here you go
this is March 4th
ok ok ok well you tell me do you need to
look at some of these songs first yes
let's do it exactly how we did it before
ok just play it and I'm gonna get going
but then you don't know the next song is
what I'm saying do you really mean are
you I'm gonna have to show you the next
soccer if you even know what it is okay
alright so Julian's gonna do this life
which I do not do but this is what you
asked for it you asked for it the men
wanted it so I don't know what they play
sort of before it but that sometimes
it's different supper it's like and now
the YouTube 15 with jenna Marbles
playing you guys writing music according
to YouTube this week and then it's like
didn't edit when they play a little
breaks or whatever and go hey guys happy
Thursday or welcome to the YouTube 15 as
I like to say that's when I record the
show haha it's me I'm in my house it's
jenna Marbles do you guys have a post my
food I do it a lot for starting off the
show this week I have up my dog
breathing into the mic isn't that you
that's him any cute
[Laughter]
keep going
well I anyway guys we're gonna start the
show off your first song what can I see
it anyway guys the hottest couple in my
opinion of all time Rihanna and Drake
whether or not it's real I like to
believe it I don't know about you hehe
here comes their song to start off the
show we have Rihanna featuring Drake
work ruff-ruff how did I do oh man we
get it we gotta play the song now my
loot list the whole thing okay so that
plays play then play the end so it goes
out like at the end I got to take me out
[Music]
wait but then the next one place then
this place stop grabbing the phone for
me then this song plays is March 2016
makes sense as the end who is I need to
know the song that's your next song
that's we just came from hold on but go
back to the YouTube app is gonna play
another song okay hey guys that was daya
and the chainsmokers don't let me down
and make sure you listen to the YouTube
15 every Saturday and Sunday repeating
on repeat every single day of the week
guys I love daya I love me some damn but
you know what I love more than me is
damn mac and cheese which is a vegan
brand of mac and cheese I like guys I
cook it at my house where I am right now
singing on the YouTube 15 here's my dog
okay coming up next next we got some
Halsey singing colors even though the
videos black and white the song is
called colors not really sure about that
decision but here we go
Halsey okay Ashley up next how's that
good really filmed in black and white
all right just a really grayscale okay
so this plays and then hey what there's
no like you're listening to the u2 15 on
it it's one oh there's no break in
between those then it's the next one
oh you mean Isaac
don't miss the show up
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys it's jenna Marbles now and that
was and that was Justin people with
sorry yes I'll do that again oh man I
wish I had a group of people that looked
that good that held up a sign that said
I heart jenna Marbles instead of my
heart JB anyway this is the you to 15
year listening to me jenna Marbles that
was Justin Bieber with sorry from
purpose the movement what a great dance
video I wish I could dance that well but
I probably can't but I'll try if you
want to watch me I'm on YouTube at jenna
Marbles coming up next coming up next
i'm jenna mourey jennamarbles
and this is a great song coming up next
because it is acoustic alright this is
one of my favourite versions of mr. John
belly on because he relates to all of us
when we're are at an all-time low
everyone this is all-time low by John
belly and coming up right now on the
YouTube 15 acoustic
that was P Amita Pia Mia do it again
featuring Chris Brown and Tyga my
favorite part of that is when they drive
the white Jeep all over the beach it
makes me feel like I'm on vacation with
them but I'm not I'm here singing the
youtubes 15 with you guys right here on
Sirius XM hits one coming up next is a
band that I can't stop listening to and
I wish I I wish I have them play-by-play
in my house live all the time that's not
an English sentence this is the 1975 my
favorite thing ever it's the sound of
the 1975 which leads me to this on the
sound by the 1975
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that was pillow talk with Zane guys I
don't know about you but I would love to
do some pillow talk about saying
honestly pillow talking with anyone
including my dogs I have three of them
I'm jenna Marbles and you listen to the
YouTube 59 hits one up next we have
Dillon Francis featuring cago come over
featuring James her see that's her it's
featuring two people actually I thought
I didn't read that right but anyway
Dillon Francis is a cool guy really
funny guy on snapchat he actually hosted
HQ trivia once
speaking of HQ trivia are you guys
playing tonight you're gonna be in for
the prize let me know I'm at Jenna
underscore marbles on Twitter I love to
engage with you
the coming up next it's a great party
song great video and here it is Dillon
Francis never lets us down what a great
guy Dylan like your song says we're
coming over now see you soon
coming up next is a song
[Music]
there's a time lapse in the beginning I
like it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's crazy that was prince royce
featuring the one and only Jennifer
Lopez back it up and pitbull cuz he's in
everything on the YouTube 15 hits one
guys I'm Jenna Marbles and I personally
love the merging of young artists with
established legends like JLo in the and
they come together so well that was
backing up one of my favorite JLo songs
of all time even though it's Prince
Royce his song thank you guys for
listening coming up next we have Katie B
Craig David major lazer Who am I well
I'm jenna Marbles but who are they
asking I don't know this is for my
featuring Major Lazer
[Music]
I'm gennaker marbles on snapchat what
I'm trying to be the most obnoxious
version of you is that okay oh it's a
version of you oh my god
[Applause]
hello is it you yeah that's right you
are you listen to the YouTube 15 hits
one that's what a delt was asking she
was asking if you were here to listen in
to this show anyway guys love me some
Adele especially wanna cry myself to
sleep but I still love her
this is that was a Dallas saying hello
for a lot of million people have heard
her say it it's a great song the whole
thing looks like it was filmed in a
dream which I love they achieved that
cinematic look I'm jenna Marbles coming
up next we have Joel Adams please don't
go this is a great video I've never
watched it it looks like it's a great
video there's some magic happening it's
see it's please don't go mmm the best
part of the song is if you hum along
with it it sounds like you're that good
at humming
it's an illusion anyway YouTube 15 hits
one during the forest please don't go
official music video demo okay that was
Cigala
easy love on the YouTube 15 hits 1 i'm
jenna Marbles wow if I could dance that
good as a kid I would have been a dancer
as an adult and as a kid but really good
at dancing in that video if you haven't
watched it it's a really good video cuz
it's just children dancing very good
very well they're good at it
their parents are probably very proud of
them shouts out to their parents and
their dance teachers we have one more
song to close this show it is the
wonderful post Malone guys post Malone
aka Austin aka the white Iverson this is
white Iverson on the YouTube 15 s1
postman we love you papa bless we know
you hang out with Ethernet Neela
we have been on their podcast we know
them we are friends with the same people
Congrats on all your success I love your
tattoos and this is a great oh and it's
saying post Malone is on tour tour June
21st at the San Diego calcoast credit
union it's advertising tickets on
YouTube that's pretty cool anyway post
Malone taking us into the weekend here
is white I'm white Iverson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks Post for taking us into the
weekend that was a great song I'm sure
all of you have heard it but if you
haven't checked out the video is pretty
cool he's just doing donuts in the
desert with his car it looks really fun
and reckless my kind of weekend am i
right anyways and gentlemen it's been
fun I'm here all week every week every
single day broadcasting live from my
home with my dogs I'm Jenna marvelous
I'll catch you guys on the Internet
next time squeaky squeaky every Thursday
and Friday and Saturday and Sunday and
Monday and Tuesday and Wednesday I'm
here with you download the app it's
called die with me I have cute dogs I
don't even know where to begin
I'm like first and foremost insulted
what but that you think I introduced
myself that many times this has never
been about me thinking you do any of
that it's my version of it true okay I
was hoping a little bit that you were
gonna do the show is you and not me but
amazing we can do that we can run it
back no I'm really okay thank you
did I trigger you overall it was a
really wonderful job sorry I didn't mean
to be I didn't mean to be too much that
too much you know you were just some hot
it was just enough that was great but I
am uh are you okay yeah okay you're not
mad at me no no matter you subscribed I
think she's mad at me
well I mean I don't know I like what I
have walked in the other day basically
like someone was singing a lyric that
was like I don't know how many dollars I
make and I was like she doesn't know how
many dollars she doesn't know how many
dogs she makes haha what IRS you're
coming for her anyway I'm Jenna miles is
YouTube 50 there was some dumb [ __ ] like
sighs so I was just trying to be like
the obnoxious radio host version it was
amazing I really I really liked that you
know what's fun though is that if we're
ever on a car trip we just have years
worth of shows that you can go through
and do that for me yeah
we laugh serious moment really quick if
you haven't listened to the show Jenna
does an incredible job as a person who's
not a radio host and doesn't make it
sound radio e she makes it sound
straightforward like very cool not
trying to be anything it's a really fun
show I'm serious like it's what coming
from the radio world watching you thrive
so well on such a huge and and massively
respected platform like Sirius XM to the
point where they've made spin-off shows
about your show is a really really proud
thing for me and I'm really excited for
all of your success and if you haven't
listened to tell you it's a great show
you're gonna learn music before most of
your friends do and I do sit right next
to her while she record so when she's
telling jokes to the show there is one
person listening to the jokes not just
you I get to hear them too they're in
the past I have done like joke dad joke
specialist for like holidays he's like I
like those what was that one dad joke
you told that I could not handle why not
it was something when I was like he
talks to women like a Klingon or
something like that
he made a Star Trek joke because there
was that one clip that you had just
recently watched of Worf being like that
is how Klingons greet women know that
it's our Klingons Laura mate those fun
knows you're fun yeah hopefully you guys
got a kick out of Jenna furiously
angrily laughing at at my terrible
impression it's also a really fun game
of you just pull a bunch of like YouTube
videos or like songs together and make
your friends pretend that they're radio
hosts and in like yeah it's kind of
amazing yeah that's actually really
funny actually a really fun game we can
do this again you know who'd be good
this game Cyrus we need to have him as
that friend of the show officially
official friendship come on man
anyway we hit some other stuff we were
talking about we ran out of time we will
move on we want to talk about like we
did a gaming tournament and it was
really fun but without first blood fun
BBB anyway we came in tenth play 10th
place y'all top top 10 Twitter eigvals
team right here are you looking at them
out of 16 but 10th lady baby
oh speaking of T I'm not gonna mention
anything else about that turtle bit
thank you guys for hanging out for
another week we appreciate it we'll be
live on Twitch throughout the week check
us out there and make sure you check out
the YouTube 15 own hits one in Aires
Fridays and Saturdays yeah
Fridays and Saturdays on the Sirius XM f
you need a free trial you know Sirius XM
/ it's Wandy team trust YouTube 15 but
likes hits one you can get a free
subscription to Sirius like I live in a
time yeah thank you guys for hanging out
we love I was fine now we're gonna go
and watch TV and probably eat some food
wonderful
[Music]
you
[Music]